now that doom fist is finally out in the  open we've all seen just how strong he  can be in the right hands but what about  on the other end  what about ways to counter do this as  much as I'd like to believe in that  sweet animated short that they had he's  not invincible and there's plenty of  heroes that can stop him right in his  tracks from Farah to McCree to soldier  76 and even junk rat here are some clips  of us killing doofus  now after watching this if you enjoyed  the video make sure to leave a like or  even consider subscribing and for those  of you who want to play as doom fists  don't forget to check out the hero guy  that made in which I run you through all  the ins and outs of new hero  someone called  [Music]  my sights